crolo vs hisoka probably the greatest
fight in all of hunter hunter no
exaggeration it is just that good it's
complex it's genius it's a spectacle and
it's also integral to our understanding
of the current arc so let's take a look
at how this one fight battle changed
this series forever hello and welcome to
the new old review your source for
morally questionable clowns my name is
liam and questionable clowns happen to
be my third favorite kind of clown right
behind digital clowns and of course
pirate clowns but crawler vs hisoka
despite seeming like a rather isolated
affair actually threatens to throw this
whole succession more in fact even the
dark continent expedition way way way
off course and into lots lots more chaos
and this video is actually part 4 of a
recap series designed to prepare you for
the return of hunter hunter in 2022 and
if you're enjoying them then please do
subscribe to the new world review tour
you know justify my life choices of
consistently talking about fictional
hunters so how did this fight first
begin well hisoka's hot date was
actually supposed to occur at the end of
york new city however crowler was uh
there well how shall we say unable to
perform after being struck by karapika's
judgment chain crowler was afflicted
with an end curse leaving him unable to
use nen or even contact the rest of the
phantom troop then after a bout of blue
balls and dodgeballs hisoka was actually
able to source a nin exorcist to remove
karapika's judgment chain which can be
seen on the cover of chapter 201 where
chrollo is also breaking the fourth wall
by reading a copy of weekly shonen jump
but this finally allowed krolow to
regain his powers and fight hisoka
eventually hisoka being the horny little
battle clown he is wanted to fight
immediately but crawler well he ran away
spending just over a year effectively
ghosting hisoka until he finally
accepted a challenge to take place in
heaven's arena which makes a lot of
sense because both crollo and hisoka are
actually floor masters and in fact
they're the only two cannon floor
masters we know of so this this was a
highly sought after match which in and
of itself was part of crolo's master
plan once arriving at the arena crolo
and hisoka both agreed that this would
be a fight to the death crowley because
he was sick of dealing with hisoku's
advances and hisoka because killing
israel is more or less like intercourse
to him i say intercourse because you
never quite know what's going to get you
demonetized on youtube and i'm pretty
sure that's a safe word maybe we'll see
hisoka however was far from safe because
crolo didn't spend the past year running
just for the sake of exercise and he had
come equipped with a whole new suite of
abilities designed specifically to kill
murder hisoka as a quick recap krollo's
primary ability is called skill hunter
and after an assortment of difficult
conditions are met it allows him to
literally steal the nen abilities of
others however on this occasion crollo
had used his nen oven to bake hisoka a
delightful ability cake because crolo
presented a new and original hatsu
called double face which is a conjured
bookmark because generally with skill
hunter crawler needs to keep his book
open at the page of the ability in order
to use it however the double face
bookmark now allows him to mark a page
with an ability close the book and then
fight with both hands oh and slightly
more terrifyingly it also means that
crollo can use two stolen abilities at
once the first by marking a page with
double face and then you can just open
the book to a new page and what are two
abilities
crawler claims that this new hot suit
did come at a cost though that cost is
well it's currently unknown to us but
allegedly it is very very annoying but
it allows kroller an ass ton of
versatility and without that very simple
bookmark this whole plan isn't actually
a plan but also this is just the
beginning because crawler would proceed
to whip out five more abilities don't
know why i did that five more abilities
to break hisoka one of which is black
voice which you may recognize as
charnock's ability it's a simple piece
of manipulation using conjured antennae
to control living targets via a conjured
remote very simple but very effective
because that's the thing about
manipulators they generally have a
one-step win condition if hisoka gets
caught with an antenna he's done and not
only that but black voice comes with two
antenna or antennae one of which crawler
generally keeps with him on hand
threatening to stick it into hisoka if
he gets too close although i imagine
that the threat of having something
stuck into him would only want to make
hisoka get closer to have a bit of a
swing crawler also went on to use a
similar heart too called orderstamp
another manipulation ability except this
one can only target puppets but by
fixing a stamp to their heads crollo can
issue them with simple commands so i say
simple because the trade-off for
orderstamp is that you can control like
literally hundreds of puppets but not
with anywhere near the complexity that
black voice can control living things
however order stamp only works well for
crollo in conjunction with another heart
too called gallery fake which belonged
to cortopi and it allowed him to make an
exact copy of any object and very
notably he needed two hands to do this
one to grab the object and the other to
generate the object and this is why the
bookmark is ever ever so important
because crawler would simply not be able
to use this ability if he had to keep
that pesky book open at all times and
the op play here is to use gallery fake
to create copies of human bodies which
appear as corpses because it cannot
replicate life and corpses well they're
kind of perfect for autostamp because
apparently this roundabout method
considers those corpses created by
gallery fake as puppets and thus crollo
can now generate an entire army of what
are essentially commandable zombies one
detriment is that gallery fake only
lasts for 24 hours but look in this case
that's that's not going to be a problem
although one very interesting side
effect noted by crolo is that puppets
created by gallery fake and controlled
with order stamp actually carry out
orders based on the personality of
whoever owns that original body which
means that the puppets under the right
or i suppose wrong circumstances could
just refuse orders as well they could
just stand there and go nah not doing it
so it's very imperfect manipulation it's
not like what illamy can do with his
needles for example which i guess is
just the price you pay for wanting to
control hundreds of hundreds of things
at once crawler's penultimate new power
is called convert hands which is quite
simple essentially if he touches someone
with his right hand then crawler takes
their appearance and if he touches
someone with his left hand then they
take his appearance and of course if he
touches someone with both hands and they
do a bit of a swip swap and this ability
is integral because it allows crawler to
hide amongst the puppets he's created
and even create some fake crawlers in
order to confuse hisoka it's kind of
like creating clones of yourself just
with real people which hisoka is going
to utterly rip apart there's a lot of
collateral damage happening in this
fight but the worst or maybe even the
best it depends on your perspective
either way that that is yet to come
crawlow's final new nun ability is
another two-hander called sun and moon
which marks his hands with a sun and a
moon but it also allows him to imprint
these markings on anyone or anything
with the big payoff being that if a sun
symbol comes into contact with the moon
symbol then they do a big explosion and
that's that's not good the size of which
is determined by how long crollow spent
in printing the symbol he could do it
instantly and create like these teeny
teeny mini explosions but if he spends
five seconds on each then that charges
the symbols to maximum and thus the
explosions are significantly bigger
however there's also a rather sinister
twist to this ability which is that it's
actually an invocation of post-mortem
net sun and moon originally belonged to
the elder of meteor city which is the
scrapyard civilization where crollo and
most of the phantom troupe grew up and
the elder was able to keep the city
relatively safe by using sun and moon to
essentially create suicide bombers so
the elder would mark a willing bomber
with sun and moon sort of like this
and defend off attackers the bomber
would just run up to them and go boom
which is brutal but effective and very
telling of how desperate the citizens of
meteor city are so desperate that after
death this ability persisted assumingly
through the raw desire of the elder to
keep the city safe and in its new amped
up post mortem then state any marks made
will never disappear even if crawler
deactivates the ability or deactivate
skill hunter as a whole these marks will
remain don't know why i'm showing you my
hands my hands are not marked thankfully
meanwhile hisoka's abilities consist of
well bungee gum and
actually just bungee gun because hisoka
doesn't even use texture surprise during
the fight but bungie gum is kind of like
the exact opposite of crowler's powers
where krolow has a very specific
assortment of swiss army men bungee gum
itself is a singular ability that
functions with all of the versatility
that hisoka's imagination can conjure so
a single ability with multiple uses
versus multiple abilities with a single
use on paper it seems like a fairly even
fight however crollo's strategy was nion
flawless so much so that he even
explained all of these abilities to
hisoka before the fight itself began in
earnest which was mainly for the benefit
of the readers but it also shows that he
was 100 confident in victory here he
also lied i mean he didn't lie but he
like very selectively told the truth to
kind of confuse he soaked anyway let's
find out if that confidence was
warranted because his strategy went a
little something like this crawler used
black voice as a faint to keep his
soaker at a distance because if hisoka
gets too close then he risks suffering a
one-hit defeat by being manipulated so
hisoka is more or less forced to
socially distance with crawler which
allows crolo to deactivate black voice
and engage in other fun powers the next
step was to use the massive crowd in
heaven's arena to make a ton of puppets
using gallery fake and then apply order
stamp to control them and send them in
to kill hisoka which means that hisoka
is busy dealing with all of the puppets
while scroller can just wander around
his heart's content to make more puppets
and at some point it gets to a critical
mass where crawler was able to use
convert hands to change his appearance
and just blend into the crown and of
course all of this requires a ton of
book switching because three of crolo 6
abilities require two hands so there's a
lot of like you need to open the book
place the bookmark close the book
usability and like reopen the book place
the bookmark again close the book use
the other ability you know and so on and
so forth basically it's not something
that would be in any way possible if
crollo didn't have a crowd of hundreds
of people ready to use hence why crollo
specifically chose heaven's arena as the
battleground now this isn't to count he
soaked her out at all he did manage to
wound crollo several times using a
bungee flail that incorporated a severed
human head but the problem is that that
was not crawler it was a very very
unfortunate spectator who crawler used
convert hands on and then injected with
black voice to assign complex actions to
make hisoka think that it was crawler
and basically this this is an
unparalleled disaster for hisoka and we
haven't even got to the worst bit yet
crolo sun and moon being post mortem
then has a very interesting interaction
with gallery fake because again these
symbols will never disappear once
imprinted which means that crawler can
deactivate gallery fake but the puppets
created will still remain in existence
because sun and moon is forcing them to
remain in existence due to its own
restrictions which in many ways meant
that crowler could have up to four
separate abilities working in tandem sun
and moon is permanent which makes
gallery fake permanent and from there
crawler is free to use two other
non-permanent abilities as he sees fit
crollo has very much min max this entire
situation which leads us to his proposed
win condition which is that all of the
gallery fake puppets were also marked by
sun and moon which turned each and every
one of them into a suicide bomber and so
with a simple command crawler could now
activate hundreds of puppet bombs
scattered all throughout the arena which
he does to great effect first blasting
off hisoka's hand and then his foot and
with significantly reduced
maneuverability hisoka was very quickly
cornered and rather unceremoniously just
dog piled by puppets at which point
crollo activated all of them and we had
a big big explosion that ultimately
killed hisoka and just like that krolow
won and hisoka legitimately died well
that is until another thing happened
during the examination of hisoka's
corpse the troop diagnosed that his
cause of death was suffocation as the
hundreds of puppet corpses had actually
cushioned his body from the bulk of the
explosion but had caused hisoka to
suffocate in the process and then we
have a bit of a flashback because hisoka
knowing that death was imminent decided
to try a gambit i mean it wasn't much of
a gambit because he had nothing to lose
he was going to die anyway but in his
last few seconds of life hisoka pleaded
with his nen and programmed it to
jumpstart both his heart and his lungs
after death and it worked hisoka's body
rather well preserved all things
considering just sprung back to life
except now he was more powerful than
ever all of hisoka's abilities and by
all i mean all two of them were now
subject to post-mortem nen allowing
hisoka to regenerate his lost body parts
using bungee gum and make them appear
real by adding a layer of texture
surprise which was something he was
certainly not able to do previously in
fact during the actual heavens arena arc
we had a similar situation where castro
managed to sever hishoka's right hand
which he very cleverly masked as being
regenerated but in reality he needed
machi to stitch it back on oh and
speaking of machi hisoka used bungee gum
to bind her and offered her a word of
warning that he was going to kill the
entire phantom troop which no in theory
includes machi but he chose not to kill
her right now for the for reasons
instead he instantly dispatched of
courtope and shortly thereafter he
killed shana which is important because
remember those two were the troop
members that crowler had to borrow
abilities off being black voice and
gallery fake so the strategy that
kroller used to beat hisoka in heaven's
arena is no longer viable now during
this time crowler was organizing for the
phantom troop to board the blackwell one
and while everyone was focused on the
dark continent the troop was going to
rob the kakin empire of all of their
amazing treasures but right now we've
had well we've had a slight change of
plans hisoka followed the troop onto the
ship and enraged by the deaths of
shalnok and cortopia crawler's number
one priority has become to find and kill
hisoka like kill for real this time but
it's not going to be anywhere near as
easy as it was before the fight in
heaven's arena like most hunt hunt
battles was completely one-sided crolo
didn't even take a single wound but that
exercise took him a whole year to plan
and it also doesn't account for the fact
that hisoka is now significantly more
powerful the next fight will not be as
one-sided and if it is that one side
will be in hisoka's favor however hisoka
is far from the troops only problem each
of them have now become embroiled in the
events of the succession war with a
series of infinitely more urgent
problems emerging which we will be
diving into in the next video